well the North Korean regime has long
been accused of appalling human rights
abuses and blame for the deaths of
hundreds of thousands of its own
citizens but there was no mention of
human rights in the agreement struck
between Kim jong-un and Donald Trump nor
the fate of thousands of prisoners in
North Korea's gulags
but let's talk now to the UN's Special
Rapporteur on human rights in North
Korea
Thomas O'Hare Quintana welcome to you
and in fact the quote from Donald Trump
was that the thousands of people in the
North Korean gulags are one of the great
winners today does that show he has
enough understanding of the conditions
for people in North Korea to be the lead
diplomatic Liana's from the joint
statement that we two leaders have
believed delivered to the international
community we haven't seen any commitment
or any reference to the serious
situation of human rights on the ground
in North Korea you mentioned the
political prison comes the situation of
these people living in those political
prison camps is dire serious grave
systemic and although the president
Trump has said that human rights was
briefly discussed during the summit the
reality is that we haven't seen any
commitment from the leader of North
Korea in this respect and my
understanding as the UN United Nations
Human Rights reporter is that there is a
need to include a human rights element
in the milk denuclearization
negotiations the situation on the ground
remains very very serious and he even
went as far to almost seem to praise his
authoritarian rule he said he's a man
who had good control of his country you
need a permit don't you in North Korea
to travel to the next town you need a
registration number plate for your
bicycle you're told what to wear you're
told the range of hairstyles you're
allowed in fact this isn't good control
this is a purist form of totalitarian
control because it is total control
the question would be in any
denuclearization agreement if you will
have a partner who has this human rights
record and how reliable would that panel
be will be in any denuclearization
agreement and the second very important
issue is I do I don't want to see the
human rights situation in North Korea to
be avoided by any agreement and that
will be the guarantees to the system
that the leader of North Korea is asking
for it's the guarantees of the system I
hope that news cameras will not be
negotiated in this context we will what
we need now from North Korea is a
gesture as a signal to the international
community that they will open up to
human rights verification to human
rights assessment to the UN Human Rights
system so far we hadn't seen anything
like that so will you be seeking
reassurances from the US about exactly
what was agreed agreed and what was
discussed and are you confident that the
Trump administration cares enough about
human rights to put it on the agenda not
long time ago recent Ram was in South
Korea being the champion in denouncing
the human rights abuses in North Korea
so I hope that the government of the
United States understands that human
rights should be in the agenda in the
denuclearization talks it's not only the
United States it's also the government
of the Republic of Korea in this very
improtant important report month between
the two the two Koreas very important
from the any Korean people from the
Korean Peninsula bad human rights in the
North Korea should be the guarantees for
an in denuclearization process I hope
that in the leadership in North Korea
shows any gesture in this respect that
that will help a lot in the process of
negotiations these important superpowers
to enjoy the state of also China and
Russia need to understand that human
rights will not go
away from the hue from the agenda the
international level and will be a very
important element for the future and the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
Thomas ahijah Quintana UN Special
Rapporteur on human rights in North
Korea thank you very much indeed for
your time thank you